nicolas bière bonjour et merci d'être en
direct avec nous ce matin alors une
journée compliquée j'imagine pour vous y
at il un avant et un après samuel pâtit
pour les professeurs et les enseignants
bien sûr on s'est retrouvé dans une
situation où des choses qui ne se
passait pas en france ou dans une
démocratie ce sont bien avoir lieu on
est un pays où le pouvoir politique a
laissé à abandonner la laïcité a
abandonné le corps professoral
abandonner toute la fonction publique à
son sort et a permis au fait que le pays
se délite au point que des forcenés des
fanatiques et voix au chapitre un timide
menace assassines dans une impunité
totale
ça a abouti au meurtre de notre
malheureux collègue samuel pâti l'an
dernier et rien que d'entendre les
propos d' emmanuel macron que vous
n'êtes pas assez je suis en colère en
colère d'entendre ce grand bourgeois à
faire des blablas alors qu'il fait
partie de ces gens de kuhn icolas
sarkozy hollande est lui même qui ont
d'élite est le pays qui ont détruit qui
ont détruit son patrimoine empêcher les
jeunes d'avoir un avenir et qui ont
saccagé la fonction publique n'ont pas
protégé les proches qui ont fait naître
pas de vagues concrètement à cause
desquelles pas de vagues et n'est pas de
vagues alertait sur ce genre de
situation qui ont abouti au meurtre de
samuel pâtit notamment rien n'a été fait
encore aujourd'hui à part des blablas à
part des commémorations dévoile à st
voilà exactement ce que vous passez en
ce moment ddd des ministres avec leurs
courtisans qui se promène de salle en
salle a serré des mains à prendre des
mines graves pour parler de choses
qu'ils ne connaissent pas qui ne vivent
pas ces gens là doivent dégager nous en
avons assez ils n'ont rien fait pour
nous les professeurs ne sont pas aidés
sont toujours aussi mal payés sont
maltraités une professeur agressé il ya
encore quelques jours dans une certaine
indifférence comme si ça devenait normal
voilà ce qui se passe un an jour pour
jour après l'assassinât de notre
collègue rien n'a été fait pour la
laïcité rien n'a été fait pour les
proches rien n'a été fait pour la
fonction publique dans ce pays et pour
la comment dire pour la solidité notre
pays rien alors hier déjà plusieurs
moments de recueillement était observée
dans les établissement scolaire
aujourd'hui ces hommages continuent d
hommage nécessaire pour se rappeler mais
aussi pour adresser des messages
alors oui le problème c'est que c'est
ces hommages dans l'excellent de classe
il gère par exemple n'ont reçu aucun
cadrage national aucun bus ministère
comme à son habitude prône une espèce
d'autonomie hyper libérale donc chacun
fait comme il veut sans cadrage national
c'est une sorte d'abandon encore le même
abandon qui a coûté la vie à samuel
pâtit le même abandon de la hiérarchie
qui a coûté la vie à samuel pâtit une
hiérarchie qui s'est même montré
malveillant à son égard d'ailleurs l'on
guette a été étouffée à ce sujet on n'a
aucun écho quid de l'inspecteur qui est
venu l'intimider pour lui demander de
céder face aux islamistes quid du
ministère qui a couvert cet inspecteur
pourquoi n'y at il aucune enquête
extérieure indépendante pourquoi n'y at
il aucune sanction pourquoi n'y at il
aucune audition à ce sujet des stylos
rouges ne comprennent pas cela non plus
où en est on trois ans maintenant après
pas de vagues rien n'a été fait rien
n'existe justement donc c'est bien les
hommages mais il faudrait peut-être
éviter que les hommages existe éviter
que les commémorations existe nous
savons bien emmanuel macron adore les
commémorations il gouverne par
commémoration faudrait peut-être faire
autre chose et prévenir les
commémorations alors vous avez parlé
voilà de ce phénomène de violence qui
existe envers certains professeurs jean
michel blanquer remise l'éducation a
fait état ce matin de 98 incidents qui
ont été relevées hier leurs dommages à
samuel pâtit comment justement peut-on
éradiquer cette ce genre de phénomène
cette violence qui est présente
aujourd'hui
mais on arrêtons de céder son arrêt en
arrêtant de rajouter des qualificatifs
des adjectifs jeu prof de français donc
voilà derrière le mot laïcité la laïcité
une unique elle doit être appliquée et
respectée point final on n'a pas besoin
de rajouter deux qualificatifs puis
peut-être en évitant de morceler la
société ya de nombreuses pistes à ce
sujet-là ans beaucoup de gens et
réfléchissent et éviter de morceler la
société de la diviser de vouloir tout
autonomiser de façon à ce qu'il n'y ait
plus du tout de corps central
je n'ai pas à refaire des français sans
pour autant être l extrême droite
essayer de redonner des projets comme
improductifs des jeunes ne soient pas
perdus et ne se jette pas dans des bras
de salafistes qui contrôle des quartiers
visiblement entier sans que rien ne soit
encore une fois parce que les gens qui
nous gouvernent nous connaissent même
pas cette réalité c'est cela même ne
savons pas combien coûte une baguette ne
savent pas prendre autre chose qu'un
taxi payés par les par
les gens présentent aux élections sont
tous les mêmes à ce sujet la coupe et
les zemmouris a fait sciences po donc
y'a un moment voilà il ya plein de
solutions mais il faudrait des gens qui
connaissent le terrain stage de quoi il
parle on a affaire à des cas ci il se
déplaçait les gardes du corps et été
entretenu par la population française
comment voulez vous que ces gens
puissent répondre aux attentes des profs
des citoyens et prévenir ce genre
d'horreur on vous dit ce qu'il ne soit
le pays dans lequel ils ne le
connaissent pas dernière question très
rapidement à votre avis dans quelle
mesure
l'assassinât de samuel pâtit at elle
impacté les professeurs dans leurs
manières d'enseigner
énormément tout le monde a peur il ya eu
une grande vague de peur qui a touché le
corps enseignant se disant mais on n'est
pas protégé on risque de se faire
assassiner on risque déjà de se faire
agresser insulter pour certains
établissements pas tous heureusement
m'enfin malheureusement beaucoup trop
les enseignants ont peur notamment
l'éducation selick histoire mais aussi
dans toutes les autres matières dans
certains quartiers peut-on encore parler
des lumières peut-on encore parler
de laïcité peut-on parler de religion
sans risquer quelque chose or qu'est ce
qui a été fait par exemple en 2011 les
inspecteurs c'est inutile courtisans du
ministre avait cherché à faire abolir
les lumières dans les programmes
scolaires il a fallu une mobilisation de
taille pour revenir là dessus il ne
fallait surtout pas froisser les
fanatiques il ne fallait surtout pas les
contrarier le tout avec la complicité
même de certains enseignants lâche voilà
il ya quelque chose à faire dans le
ministère à la presse du ministère mais
aussi à la tête de l'état il faut du
volontarisme ce niveau là il faut
combattre l'obscurantisme
grignote des quoi entier de la
république sont plus rien ne soit fait
merci beaucoup nicolas guyart pour votre
témoignage je rappelle que vous êtes
enseignant professeur de français et
membre des styles anges merci à vous